- Cela fait maintenant presque
au Canada. Cet ancien interprète
a travaillé pour l m militaires
canadiens en Afghanistan
avant de devoir fuir son pays.
dernier, quelques jours après
son arrivée.ujujourd'hui,
le jeune homme s'épanouit.
Il travaille dans un magasin,
se fait des amis.
Mais popossible de ne pas
penser aussi chaque jour
Mais impossible de ne pas
à sa famille restée au pays
et à ses anciens confrères
nombreux à tenter de quitter
l'Afghanistan et à attdrdre
des nouvelles du Canada,
qui a promis de les aider.
Si Sahil a finalement pu venir
d'un groupe de Canadiens.
Mais le gournrnement a aussi
mis en place un programme
d'immigration spécial pour ceux
avec les Canadiens
en Afgninistan.
Depuis un an, quelque 15 000
demandes ont ainsi été reçues
Mais seulement 7000 personnes
so a arrivées à destination.
Ce major-général retraité
est de ceux qui, l'été dernier,
avaien
d'agir pour évacuer ces Afghans
menacés.
S'il reconnaît les défis
logistiques de cette mission,
les lourdeurs du processus
de demande et un manque
de communication.
comme celui pour les interprètes
préoccupe aussleles organismes
impliqués.
WENDY LONG, fond. et présidente,
- C'est un risque aux gens
qui vontêêtre laissés
en Afghanistan. Nous ne devrions
pas avoir des limites avec ceux
- Leur inquiétude,
esest aussi que l'Afghanistan
s'efface des mémoires.
en Ukraine, l'attention des gens
s'est déplacée, note-tlllle.
Et bien sûr, les Ukrainiens
méritent cette attention.
les Afghans."
Le gouvernement canadien répète
pour sa part que son objectif
total d'accughghghghghghghghghgn
des plus ambitieux au monde et
qu'il poursuit son engagement.
Ici Camille Gris Roy,
Rad